[Music]
so there has been a woman who worked in
a prison type who explains why she'll
never uh
put stickers on her car
that's actually you shouldn't put
cigarettes what do you mean because it
marks it i never put stickers on my car
either well i will refuse it's tacky
because
you wouldn't absolutely
no i wouldn't i just don't want to be
recognized at all like i don't want
people to be like oh i saw it like i've
been following don't you have like a
rainbow tesla that you posted about for
real though
don't you have [ __ ] two hand tattoos
and [ __ ]
increase nobody know who i am
okay so wait are you calling me cool
i'll call you it's cool but you're
definitely recognized
that's a headbutt that's the first jk
news headbutt yeah i forgot how violent
she is so so this this lady's name is
michaela katarina she shared the
necessary precautions she's taking after
working in a correctional facility
from things like not put yes aka joe
from things like not putting stickers on
your car too even wearing appropriate
shoes so let's go down a couple of these
precautions appropriate issues what what
are the sticker thoughts that anybody
has makes you identifiable and also we
have to remember uh women perceive the
world differently than men perceive
themselves because i feel like first
sexist continuing way more
i don't like those stickers with the
family catalog like the the two parents
members the dog the kids
you know what that's for right it sounds
salty it's so like people are a little
more mindful of them on the road because
they have kids yes stupid you [ __ ]
idiot wow
hey guess what nowadays no one's mindful
how about that nobody's [ __ ] mindful
of how they drive every
real quick i gotta get this off my chest
at the gym that i work at the gym that i
work at there's a stop light [ __ ]
open there's a there's a [ __ ] stop
light that pulls up that's right next to
our gym and we have a big window every
person that pulls up to that stoplight
everyone's on their [ __ ] phone dude
no one's ever paying attention to the
road and that's all i have to say what's
your point about they're trying to be
like yo this is lionheart this is the
place that nick the year's at that's
what they're doing you have all these
people that are worried about like
you have what was your point about the
family sticker thing
you were the one that said you hated it
this is why i have him on genius
breakdown what's your point though this
guy is the man at starting a story and
not knowing where it's going
i don't know you guys were talking about
no no you guys are like being careful of
the people on the road nobody gives a
[ __ ]
you guys want to see the funniest thing
that this guy does i love watching this
guy like after we train at the gym right
my favorite thing to do is watch him
leave because i've never seen he's
walking
i've never seen somebody get into their
car so fast and exit before he even
closes the door like
it's almost a magic trick i'm like how
the [ __ ] did you start your car like
when you this is you push the start like
this is the car right this is the car
this is you when we watch him leave
tonight watch he just goes like this he
opens the door the car just started
yo i was like yo warm that [ __ ] up how
did you do that you know what i think in
my head i'm like is this bad for my car
i think it is i believe now you're good
also nick is the angriest driver i've
ever been in the car with two oh wait
let's man
and he's on his phone too oh
i'm on my phone
[Applause]
i'm on my phone when i drive would i be
doing what do i be doing
no i've been in the car with the
multiple i will say nick gets angry as
[ __ ] when he drives though like what and
i bet
i've been behind him too in the cars and
watching him and he's just like
he's just mad i'm like damn my boy
matter right now right yeah good deal
why yeah we're calling him out but
what's the list
yeah what was the tip
hey hey what were the tips
but i do i do feel like women are gonna
perceive it differently than men so her
list i feel like she's gonna be like no
well especially
especially her occupation she's extra of
a target yeah yeah people people be cat
connor all the time see the funny thing
is she says i will never put one of
those stick
stick figure families on the back of my
car or put any kind of identification on
my vehicle she proves my point because
people can tell if you're single or if
you have children and they don't need to
know that information exactly that's
what because they got homies on the
outside you know what i mean but
my point was why you put the [ __ ]
stickers on the my whole thing was don't
put those stickers on your car that was
my point
and then you guys are like oh people
it's for people to understand
let's talk about this since we're on jk
news all right
so
there has been a myth around here that
nick is the nicest person to spar
alex
would you like to state how hard he
spars you ain't no comment
blast be me will you i i will spar hard
oh yeah i thought you were a sandbagger
he's the sandbagger when i spar with
alex i just make sure he gets good
working oh good work means a bloody nose
yeah have i ever made you bleed
i've never made you blue
i don't make nobody
let's talk about this story real quick i
like this story it was a sunny day out
in sierra madre whatever you got i got
eight more of them oh well let's go then
baby let's go story for story let's go
let him tell a story and we'll tell the
dylan story it's all good
hey hey let's continue we're going to
talk about the story so did you say
dildo's story you want how gangster this
[ __ ] fool is bring us in the [ __ ]
circle please this is dude
we train right we have our buddy
his name
is ricky all right when these two spar
it's like fireworks it's [ __ ] nuts
[ __ ] dope so they're they're doing
mma sparring right ricky somehow gets
him in a crucifix you know what this
will says this is supposed to be
sparring right he goes hurry up and do
something [ __ ]
oh that's real friendly dude
so i don't want to hear you become
never in my life
that it was real like he just wasn't
doing nothing i was like hey let's work
what's going on oh yeah yeah
yeah that's the same thing while he's in
a lot yeah yeah and i will say that nick
did get angry that day and of course i
was around after him
[Laughter]
when i saw nick's face i was like [ __ ]
what happened though it wasn't bad his
bill alex was like damn i gotta get it's
all worked up as [ __ ]
it just me and heinrich we have a we
have a very special relationship because
bro he's like my brother bro like we and
you can [ __ ] him up because he's not he
[ __ ] me up i [ __ ] you like he goes back
and forth he [ __ ] me i [ __ ] like
nick can hit me a little harder i don't
even hit you hard bro yeah i know but
like to other people it might look like
he's hitting me hard but like on the
other on the other hand there was one
story where david got hit with a hard
hand and literally just beat the [ __ ]
out of him hold on a second let me
explain the story that sounds like david
tell him the whole story dylan was in
this position and got hit so i already
went
oh that's how hard he started dancing
because he was so happy
nah nah it was it was like this look
dylan is a friend he's like he's a good
friend so you can [ __ ] up all your
friends super he works for super rare
he's a good dude this dude this
[ __ ] was sparring with david and
i know dylan's not his experience yeah
right so he's sparring with david they
thought him too nah they were it was
amicable but like when you get new
people that haven't really sparred that
much sometimes they don't really know
how hard they hit we don't know yeah
they they could kind of hit a little
hard and that guy punched david in the
face and it happened to be the very
first punch and he was being really nice
and then he got punched in the face hard
so then he was like all right i guess
we're doing this now so then they start
sparring things start to escalate and it
was very one-sided on david's part david
is
it's almost like they're having a it's
like the analogy is is like him and
dylan are having a verbal conversation
but dylan's not saying a word
and dylan and david's like shut the [ __ ]
up dylan you know but with punches but
with punches and the whole time i'm on
the outside trying to be a good coach
like hey bring it down bring it down hey
like lower like 50 david 50
he's ignoring me to the point where i'm
like i can't be a part of this and i
walked away oh wow
that's the coaching you go i go all
right then i'm out i stay i stayed and
watched the whole [ __ ] thing this one
over here i heard popcorn in the corner
dude
yeah there's [ __ ] instigating
let's just say this let me just reframe
this a little better all right it was a
warm beautiful sunny day of sierra
all right the sun was shining the birds
were chirping god was out now listen
dylan's a very nice guy i actually like
him a lot right he looks like lex luthor
this guy isn't that the antagonist
just to give you a frame of what he
looks like so
dylan if he's watching this video so you
want to be you have to understand the
way dylan talks dylan talks as if he's
trained his whole don't try to defend it
bro it was it was one session listen to
me so so
when i when i hear people speak and they
talk about their training i get excited
because now i'm like oh this guy can
show me some [ __ ] by the way he showed
up with his blue belt for some reason
his jiu-jitsu blue belt hanging out of
his back i gotta stay strapped we're
and so
in my mind i'm thinking like oh he's
gonna he's gonna watch after me because
he's the more experienced fighter from
the way that he was talking and so so
then you beat his [ __ ] ass hold on a
second hold on do something [ __ ] all
right so let's start this story so
literally when you're sparring right
there's a way to set the tempo i set the
tempo by throwing a light jab and i mean
like this
and he [ __ ] overhand
cracks me full clip in the mouth
and then my jaw hurt for like two weeks
after that's how hard he [ __ ] hit me
i had no mouth piece here and david's
face went like this let me let me do
your face real quick right after you got
hate went
[Laughter]
this little pat this little pat looked
at me he goes he started laughing i was
like why don't you laugh he goes it
looked like you just tasted some of the
best food you had in your life
i was like
and so when he hit me the first thing
that i think about so years ago
when we first started training i i went
to this gym out in sacramento and so
when people know that you're a youtuber
they try to make a [ __ ] tick-tock
click about you so i had a little
flashback of that because people just
start to wail on you because they're
trying to make you a highlight i'm
trying to make this hey what's up baby
so when he cracked me all i saw was red
i was like hey we're supposed to be
friendly you're alex's friend why'd you
hit me so hard it's all i thought but i
was like oh if we're throwing down then
let me throw the same pace that you did
to me and so i thought he was gonna be
better than he was and after that first
round i was like oh he's actually not
that good he just talked i think he just
kind of like talked himself up a little
bit so we didn't go a second round after
that we just left it peacefully we
didn't let you go second round
it wasn't like a choice on his part you
know
after he gave him ct [ __ ] cte a
little bit so did you guys witness the
did he get cracked pretty hard oh yeah
no the very so was it justified that no
was i was i like david bro hey you got
to relax
well he explained to me he goes when you
go against people who are inexperienced
just use your defense but in my mind i
didn't think he was inexperienced and
yeah i know but at the same time i was
like but he is yeah but then you can
tell the only i'll defend dylan in a
sense nick was like hey yo bring it down
a bit
hey hey lighting up a little bit david
and he started going further and further
away
and i was like i'm gonna go sit in my
car and then he got to his car to drive
and then the next day i was at work and
then dylan's like damn david beat the
[ __ ] out of me yesterday i was like
you